speaking of the climate variations on a
theme it's time for this day in history
this day in history on this day in
history nearly an inch of snow fell
every hour for 16 consecutive hours
starving cattle and ruining ranchers in
the American West know that extreme
weather didn't happen last year or the
year before that or the year before that
nope the worst day of the worst winter
in the West took place 131 years ago
long before Democrat hacks ever blamed
weather events unfold apocalyptic
theories plains ranchers in Montana
Wyoming and the Dakotas knew nothing of
the ozone layer or the greenhouse effect
or political demagogues seizing upon any
natural phenomenon to tighten their grip
on power if they had surely they would
have blamed the unseasonable hot and dry
summer of 1886 on I don't know
industrialization or deforestation or
whatever that unseasonable dry autumn
left the range almost completely barren
of grass with vulnerable cattle herds
wandering around hungry worse yet the
snows came early that year beginning in
November and blanketing the plains by
January with a record snowfall the cold
front even reached the Pacific Ocean
dropping an all-time record 3.7 inches
of snowfall in downtown San Francisco on
February 5th although a warm wind
briefly melted top layers of January and
that actually turned out worse because
the returning cold created a thick layer
of ice over the entire ground making it
virtually impossible for cattle to dig
through to the remaining grass beneath
futile attempts on the part of man to
predict the weather years out compounded
the problem by the mid 1880s after
several consecutive warm winters the
warmest winters on record they probably
thought Frodo climatologists in the West
started over stocking the ranges with
cattle while they simultaneously stopped
storing away winter feed for a snowy day
modern climatologists can simply change
their models hide the decline when their
predictions don't come to fruition while
political hacks explain away their
failures and at the same time double
down on their own hysterical claims the
plains ranchers of 1886 and 18
seven weren't so lucky they had to sit
by and watch as their cattle slowly died
historian Joseph Kinsey Howard recalled
starving cattle staggered through
village streets and collapsed and died
in dooryards 5,000 of the animals
stormed the outskirts of Great Falls
devouring what little the townspeople
had only just planted and crying from
hunger as they died the great died up as
it came to be called because the
American West is very whimsical
killed off millions of cattle including
half of Montana's entire herd their
carcasses lined the countryside hundreds
of ranchers fell into sudden bankruptcy
some modern climate prognosticators are
willing to send whole national economies
into bankruptcy even as their
predictions continually prove just as
inaccurate as Western speculators in the
1880s but the alarmists keep up their
hysterical drumbeat the science has
settled they say the solutions are
obvious it's just common sense we have
seen the future and it works right also
on this day in history in 1776 Thomas
Paine published his pamphlet common
sense in it he writes quote a long habit
of not thinking a thing wrong gives it a
superficial appearance of being right
and raises at first a formidable outcry
in defense of custom time makes more
converts than reason pain may have been
more right than he knew in decadent
times common sense is anything but
sensible
as the predictions of self-appointed
elites prove wrong time and time again
don't be fooled by superficial
appearances and do not forfeit your own
capacity to reason